Speaker 1: y with a shift in the balance of power
potentially in the Senate. Days after Herschel
Walker, thankfully, was defeated by the incumbent
Democratic senator from Georgia, Raphael Warnock,
and we said what great news. It won't be 5050
in the Senate, but it will be 5149 in favor of
Democrats. Democratic but shaky Democrat. Let's
call her what she is shaky. Democrat Kirsten
Cinema announces she is leaving the Democratic
Party and becoming an independent. Now I know.
I know, I know. Let's resist the urge to call
this what it may be at face value a desperate
attempt for attention from someone who, by virtue
of the Democrats getting 51 rather than 50 seats,
immediately, has a diminished amount of power
in the Senate in the sense that she alone cannot
prevent Democrats from getting a simple majority.
Let's actually sort of talk it through and see
what she had to say. NPR reporting. Here is what
cinema's switch from Democrat to Independent could
mean for the Senate. And the article explains
cinema's move is unlikely to change the power
balance in the Senate as it comes days after
Senator Raphael Warnock won the Georgia runoff
election to give Democrats a 51 to 49 majority.
That includes two independents who caucus with
Democrats. Those are, of course, Senators Bernie
Sanders of Vermont and Angus King of Maine. Cinema
said she doesn't want to fit in a box, and the
article goes on to talk about the direction that
the Senate could go in and also talks about
Arizona's 2024 outlook. As Kirsten Cinema is
up in 2024 and the fact that she is no longer a
Democrat could of course, mean that now Democrats
could hold a primary and have a candidate who runs
against cinema. You could end up with a Democrat,
a Republican and independent Kirsten Cinema in
Arizona. That would change the dynamics of that
race. But we're going to table that for the time
being. Here's my my primary thought about this.
And we're going to hear from Bernie Sanders
in a moment about this. My primary thought.
Is that this does seem motivated
by a desire for attention,
particularly with the win by Raphael Warnock.
It seems as though the question now is,
well, is it 51, 49 or is it 5050? And the
question really has to do with caucusing.
Angus King and Bernie Sanders are not Democrats,
but they caucus with Democrats. And that's where
we got for the last two years. It's 5050 rather
than 48, 50 and two. Let's listen to what Kirsten
Cinema had to say. She was interviewed by Jake
TAPPER about this powerful decision that she made.
Speaker 2: You're here to make a significant
announcement. I'm registered as an Arizona
Independent. I know some people might be a
little bit surprised by this, but actually
I think it makes a lot of sense.
Speaker 1: We're not that
surprised. Kirsten, you know.
Speaker 2: A growing number of
Arizonans and people like me just don't feel
like we fit neatly into one party's box or
the other. And so like many across the state in
the nation, I've decided to leave that partizan
process and really just focus on the work that
I think matters to Arizona and to our country,
which is solving problems and getting things done.
Speaker 1: Now understand that.
Being in the being in the Senate and being
a Democrat and then saying, I'm leaving the
Democratic Party because I no longer fit into that
box. Now I'm outside of Partizanship. This is one
of the silliest things. I mean, we've talked about
this before. It's sort of like people who say, I
don't vote because I think all of these excuse me,
Republican politicians and Democratic politicians,
none of them have our best interests in mind.
So I'm above and outside of the partizan fray
by never voting for any of these losers. That's
a very political decision. It's still political.
And I would argue it is still partizan, because
you're basically saying I don't see an appreciable
difference between Democrats and Republicans,
even though there are so many differences that
I'm saying they're equally bad and I'm voting for.
That's a very partizan and political statement.
So this is starting to get into the kind of
enlightened centrism that we've been critical of.
Let's listen to the rest of her statement here.
Speaker 2: So your voting record is pretty capital
D Democratic. I mean, your views are generally
that of a moderate, centrist Democrat. How
does leaving the party change how you do your
job? Well, I don't think anything will change
about how I do my job. Arizona sent me to the
United States Senate to be an independent voice
for our state, and I'll continue doing that.
Speaker 1: That's a classic, by the way. Oh,
I was sent here to be an independent voice,
to think for myself. All right. But now it is
interesting. I will mention that there is footage
of Kirsten Cinema chastising Joe Lieberman for
doing the exact same thing, going from the
Democratic Party to Independent. She did. Now
she's doing it. And now it's great. Now it's
a sign of virtue. But in the past, she was
critical of Joe Lieberman for doing exactly that.
Speaker 2: But they negotiated with the Senate. So
what does that mean? Well, in the Senate, we no
longer have 60 votes. Some would argue we never
had 60 because one of those was Joseph Lieberman.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 2: But so whatever question to
bear with Lieberman. So so now there's
I think, as the president so eloquently said
on Wednesday, there's none of this pressure,
this fast pressure to get to 60. So what that
means is that the Democrats can stop kowtowing
to Joe Lieberman and instead seek other avenues.
Speaker 1: Isn't that interesting, the way that
they've had to kowtow or will have to kowtow to
Kirsten Cinema and Joe Manchin? So the hypocrisy
adds to my feeling that this is a plea for
attention and she's getting the attention
and here I am covering it as well because
it is relevant. We will have to see if and
how this changes cinema's voting. Let's now
talk about the reaction from Bernie Sanders.